well you're here at the Milken
conference talking disruptive innovation
I'm tired of hearing that term because
we hear it so much is it overused what
does it mean to you the word disruption
I could see how one can say it's
overused like 10 years ago the word
disruption wasn't the word it was
innovation and 40 years ago the word
innovation wasn't really used was called
invention so just I feel it's because of
the democratization of everything you
know you now can say you know i wish i
wish this did that and now that person
that has the vision to wish it did that
can actually make that happen that's
disruption is to see a hole or void in
either culture politics you know
education consumer electronics and bring
to life manifest the thing you think is
missing has being a disruptor made you
more powerful so you aren't beholden to
a music label a company of school you
have said everything you're involved in
you've said why I don't want to do it
that way I'm going to push back is that
what empowers you
no first the idea and the desire of
feeling that voice comes first you can't
just disrupt for disruption purposes
like you can't just say like hey I feel
like disrupting today that's like again
do that one thing you are known for is
creating universal anthems songs that
connect two generations at certain times
of year they become these pivotable
pivotal sounds symbols how do you create
that traveling going to like Brazil and
seeing like you know what a festival you
know environment is like a carnival go
into Japan and going to like you know
underground club in Japan going to
birthday parties weddings going to you
know top clubs going to you know
Coachella's and glass and berries and
then pattern matching seeing what the
similarity is in all those different
places that are traveled and then say
you know what I think the I think
culture needs this it's like being the
tailor for pop culture alright your
favorite song of your songs of your
music your number one favorite that you
could listen to a thousand times if you
want your kids to fall in love with I'm
rule yet in your experiences what if you
love the most the most proud of
I got a villain ah I love that all the
reason it's like I come from the
projects right and my neighborhood was
amazing that would play at lunch a doze
and cumbias it was like all men Cano
where I grew up and to think that I have
a song that it's big in Mexico and big
in Brazil and big in Israel dig all over
the world and I go back to that little
kid that was riding the bike through the
projects going playing basketball
Costello park I was that little kid in
the projects riding the bike rapping to
himself that little kid he designed me
that little 13 year old Willie made me
and I'm I think I made that little 13 yo
were proud for riding I gotta feeling